well I mean I don't see myself as being
religious per se I do tend just I do try
to think that I'm sort of i'm part they
were all part of a larger being and I
think that helps me be empathetic toward
towards others so I'm I think that
something is ur runs through many many
religions sore the do unto others as you
know do want done unto you or what have
you I think you sort of see that in
every religion III believe that and I
think my philosophy I'd like to to
contribute more than I take yeah I'm
think in general like I'd like to have a
bigger impact we live in a very strange
world where you know a very small
percentage of us live very comfortable
lives and a very large percentage of us
live quite uncomfortable lives so I'd
really like to I think I'm very
privileged and I'd really love to help
those less privileged to live better
lives
I'm certainly not a political junkie by
any stretch I do my best to read
treehugger on a regular basis so i don't
i believe the government is a very
important part I think there's sort of a
three-legged stool and that's in terms
of green let's I'm probably in terms of
most things there's a consumer there's
business and there's government and I
think they play play a very important
role as do the others so I do think
politics are very important and I
haven't really I haven't really played
much in that realm and I don't know I'll
be interesting to see if I will I don't
know if I have the baby well i think i'd
like to have given much more than I took
away I think I think it's really that
it's really that simple
you